TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
If you haven't heard,
Google I/O this year
is mid-May, right here, in
Mountain View, California.
You can now apply for tickets
and must do so by 5:00
PM Pacific Time on
February 27 by going
to the link in the
description below.
Winners will be notified
by email on the 28th.
Last week, we hosted the first
annual TensorFlow Developer
Summit where we
announced TensorFlow 1.0.
It's faster, more flexible, and
more production ready than ever
before.
For all the details
for this release
as well as videos of all the
sessions from the Dev Summit,
please follow the link
in the description below.
And while we're on the
topic of machine learning,
you may want to check
out TensorFlow debugger.
It's a tool that makes
debugging of machine learning
models in TensorFlow easier.
Get started by following
the link to the post.
We're rolling out
more custom styling
and data object
association features
in the Google Maps Android
API to further help
you customize your maps.
Head on over to the post to
learn about styling and custom
data for polylines and polygons.
Also, you may have noticed
our Maps API tutorials
have a new look with complete
step-by-step instructions
for the most common use
cases and code up front.
Please let us know what
you think on the post.
When building
cloud applications,
database administrators
and developers
have been forced to choose
between traditional database
that guarantee transactional
consistency or NoSQL databases
that offer simple horizontal
scaling and data distribution.
Cloud Spanner offers both of
these critical capabilities
in a single
fully-managed service.
Get started on the post.
Oh, and one more thing
on Google Cloud Platform.
NVIDIA Tesla K80 GPUs
are now in public beta.
You can now spin up
NVIDIA GPU-based VMs
in three GCP regions.
For more details
and to get started,
follow the link to the post
in the description below.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[TYPING AND PRINTING]
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right here.
Just click on them.
[DIALING]